uncharted good multiplayer fun it's like
a win uncharted 3 multiplayer beta not
the full game yet but this is still cool
so as you know I'm a big fan of the
Uncharted games and so Sony's released
to us the multiplayer beta to uncharted
3 and it's actually a lot of fun I mean
usually you know how betas are they're
like all right here's one map and here's
like two characters and a couple of guns
you know have fun this is like an entire
multiplayer game you only have a couple
maps to go on but you have like nine
modes if your basic like team deathmatch
modes and you have like your all-out
deathmatch modes where everyone fights
everyone and everyone kills everyone you
realize how much you suck no seriously
you thought the computer was really good
at throwing a grenade in your pocket
there was this one guy he was running I
don't think he actually looked at me he
was just like would you just threw a
grenade on my big toe and it blew up
made that sound - whatever then I was
like you know what break my neck like a
man you which is cool that you
can do you can go behind people and just
snap their necks the most gratifying
thing ever because there's nothing
cooler than having a shot gonna be in
luck I could shoot that guy in the back
or I could snap his neck although I hate
it when it's done to me someone snaps my
neck I'm like you know you have a gun
for a reason shoot me like a man yeah
just hate dying there's no other way to
slice it I don't like dying in games
there you have a couple of modes that
are kind of story based it's nathan
drake elena and sullivan they're doing a
puzzle and you know floods of guys are
coming in you got to take them out it
feels like you're playing a part of
uncharted 3 the game which is kind of
cool since it's like you know doesn't
come out until november one of the
coolest modes that have is called
plunder it's capture the flag but
there's just one treasure and that is
like the Uncharted thing you know it's
like one treasure everyone's going after
it and this treasure goes back and forth
and whatever team gets it to the other
side and puts it in their chest like
five times wins but I swear to God this
was like Looney Tunes one guy got the
treasure about five grenades we're all
like Bud blew up that guy gets
annihilated someone from the other team
picks it up that guy gets shot in the
head someone else comes and picks up the
treasure from the other team that guy
gets his neck broken someone else comes
from the other team shotguns that guy in
the face this went on like for ten or
twenty intervals in the course of about
20 kills that thing gained a distance of
about 5 feet maybe laughs it was
probably the funnest game mode I think
I'm pretty good with sniper rifles
though but in this beta I wasn't I'd get
on the sniper rifle and then someone
else would smack me with a sniper rifle
and I'd be like yeah go ahead and sniper
rifle me you know what break my neck
like a man anything happened to me where
I was actually ahead then I got marks I
was marked for death like everyone could
see there was a big ol err
above my head reminded me of Mario Kart
where you're like sweet I'm in first
awesome that's a spiked shell if
someone's gonna shove up my ass that's
great who wants to be in first word of
advice go for the silver medals my
friends cuz no one wants to kill the
second-place guy and there was another
really fun game mode where it was like
me and a couple other people we just had
to like fend off waves of guys now for
me first-person games a multiplayer
easier to play than third person games
now granted and the multiplayer for
Uncharted it's really cool to have like
Nathan Drake's athletic prowess you can
climb walls get up on roofs you know all
the stuff that you do in Uncharted but
it's the third person game so you gotta
mind the camera also nothing's worse and
it's like he's getting frantic you know
when you're running from guys and you
somehow soom to the camera around to the
side of your head facing down and you're
like I can't say I'm done dead alright
yeah someone broke my neck you know you
have a gun for a reason shoot me like a
man and you can turn on voice and then I
don't like voice cuz you turn on voice
in your life hey man how's it going
greetings from America greetings to you
wicked featureless you like
piece of Marcos do this okay
I'm not a fit Tiger have what can I say
you know you have a gun for a reason
shoot me like a man so the multiplayer
beta is going on until the 14th I guess
I'm out of touch I didn't know it was
gonna end so soon I would have gotten
you this video sooner but you still have
from now until the 14th to play and i
really suggest it's a free download it
is a free complete multiplayer
experience it's really good game playing
fun multiplayer modes so it's like no
reason not to do it if you have a
PlayStation 3 there's no reason not to
download it and play it if you don't
download and play this multiplayer beta
someone's gonna get away with murder
oh wait I've been looking for a way to
put that jab in there found it so if you
played the uncharted 3 multiplayer beta
what did you think about it what's your
favorite mode comment below let me know
for you Xbox people you can write
something xbox II I guess but if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]